j'en ai ramené avec moi pour moi c'est
pour moi si vous voulez l'essayer
pourquoi c'est parce que ça va plaire à
tout le monde non mais c'est vrai que
mon peuple a dit non j'adore attends je
vais voir ce que je peux faire tu crois
que tu à matane
donc c'est pour garder ou quartz sur
pièce d'accord il ya plusieurs
applications livres qui peut se porter
de plusieurs manières en fait un moyen
pour les femmes qui ne sont pas voilées
par exemple on peut le porter
directement en maillot d'accord j'ai du
soleil d'accord alors là en fait c'est
un maillot il n'ya rien quand il est
juste que ça se trouve c'est un maillot
comme un autre non mais c'est un maillot
manches longues il est beau ou qu'il a
metz la jolie ouais franchement
et ça ne veut pas montrer ses formes
trout de trop près on va dire on va
rajouter cette petite jupe d'accord
d'accord il mais rien sur le web sur la
tête si vous voulez en fait à part
obligatoire c'est pas obligatoire à
corse avait en fait c'est si une femme à
l'envié de se couvrir la tête avec ça
pour vous couvrir la tête à la piscine
oui maintenant me voilà donc lorsque
tout le monde le fait un petit peu vu
que la plupart du temps le bolide
piscine est obligatoire exactement c'est
vrai d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai
une tête de con à la piscine mais je
suis pas ouf normalement mal à la racine
c'est pire alors je voudrais voir ce qui
d'abord soutiennent cette décision
gilles verdez ou la soutenir oui c'est
une grande décision pour la liberté la
liberté des femmes et est aussi une
femme musulmane me disais aussi pour les
enfants parce qu'à plein d'enfants qui
ne pouvait pas être accompagnés par leur
maman est donc enfin ces enfants j avais
pas pensé mais c'est vrai enfin ces
enfants pourront aussi aller à la
piscine donc je suis très content de
cette décision c'est bien c'est
simplement un vêtement il ya aucun
communautarisme là dedans il faut qu'on
s'y habitue en norvégien la en suède
vous pouvez même loué un burqini pour
aller à la piscine à rennes ça se passe
très bien donc c'est une très belle
décision alors elisabeth vous n'êtes pas
d'accord non je ne suis pas d'accord
alors d'abord je voudrais commencer par
dire que je n'ai absolument pas la
moindre animosité personnelle contre des
femmes qui le portent je voudrais vous
expliquer j'aimerais vraiment vous
convaincre en paix bien entendu vous
n'arrivez pas je ne crois pas non mais
je voudrais vous au moins que vous
compreniez pourquoi ça heurte une partie
de vos concitoyens de nos concitoyens
une grande partie à en croire les
sondages puisque c'est entre 60 et 70%
voulait selon les études donc ça doit
vous poser une question je veux dire
vous êtes française vous comprenez que
une de vos pratiques woerth un certain
nombre de gens bien entendu je ne
comprenais pas je vous explique après
vous allez me répondre je vous assure
bien entendu c'est parce que nous n'y
voyons pas un vêtement ni un maillot
comme un autre d'abord ce vêtement a été
poussé par des associations qui ne sont
absolument pas neutre nous avons vu les
gens qui ont poussé des cris de joie à
l'annoncé de la décision ce sont des
acides des associations qui pratiquent
une forme d'entreprise islamistes
derrière d'autres causes et si vous
voulez maintenant tout le monde le sait
et qui essayent d'ailleurs de séparer
les musulmans du reste de la population
en leur disant toute la journée on vous
aime pas ou aux plats moi je vous prends
pour des adieux vous prend pour une
adulte et donc j'estime que je peux vous
formuler des critiques sans que ce soit
prêt comme une déclaration de haine de
racisme ou de je ne sais pas quoi alors
là ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que l'égalité entre les individus et
sacré d'accord mais cette égalité entre
les individus ne suppose pas que sur le
sol français il y ait égalité entre tous
les pratiques culturelles les musulmans
sont des tout à fait les bienvenus dans
ce pays ils sont arrivés plus tôt plus
tard que les autres et c'est une
minorité et minorités vous avez deux
solutions la solution suédoise puisque
gilles verdez incité la suède où
d'autres pays
multiculturaliste qui met toutes les
pratiques à égalité et vous avez la
solution française où ce que nous disons
ce qu'on a dit à mes parents quand ils
sont arrivés par ce moment je ne viens
pas de français de souche si voulez vous
arrivez dans un pays magnifique mais qui
a un certain nombre de règles pour le
biberon ensemble les catholiques ont été
je veux dire très violemment
heurté par la loi de 1905 équipe à deux
c'est une question de laïcité je dis
juste pour leur a demandé de rentrer la
religion dans l'espace privé ils l'ont
fait vous si vous voulez ce que nous
demandons ça n'est pas aux gens de
renoncer c'est de comprendre que ça
heures plusieurs choses chez nous 1
effectivement la discrétion dans
l'espace public on ne jette pas sans
religion à la passe d audit chez nous
vous parler de petit mars en france chez
nous en france connaissent pas chez nous
en france en seine reconnaissant notre i
dans notre pays qui est un pays
singulier parce qu'il ya deux modèles si
vous voulez ya le multiculturalisme
c'est mc donald's venez comme vous êtes
ça marche pas très bien on prête même
eia l'assimilation républicaine
c'est à dire à rome tu fais comme les
romains les moeurs françaises la
minijupe ma mini jupe n'a pas le même
statut que votre burkini parce que votre
burkini n'est pas français vous vous
êtes française mais votre burkini ne
l'est pas est ce qu on demande
simplement à l'islam et à toutes les
eaux toutes les autres cultures comme
elles l'ont fait avant si vous voulez
c'est de dire nous nous adaptons nous
nous adaptons il y à signaler 70 % de
vos concitoyens qui sont révoltés par
cette pratique c'est parce que ça heurte
notre conception de la liberté des
femmes d'aller chez nous le corps des
femmes n'a pas ce catch est d'accord et
que ça heurte aussi notre conception
d'une certaine unité nos différentes
bien sûr existe mais dans le fond les
échos où les exhibe le moins possible
sur la place publique voilà et ça n'est
pas du tout une question de racisme et
encore moins une question d'animosité
contre vous mais oui la vie en société
suppose de renoncer à certaines libertés
et la france c'est pas mac do d'accord
je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'animosité
envers moi personnellement je vous crois
mais il y avait quelque chose contre
l'islam je pense moi ce que je vais vous
dire déjà c'est que le burqini n'est pas
une histoire on va dire ne concerne pas
que les musulmanes ce n'est pas de base
il a été créé par une styliste
australienne donc rien à voir avec avec
une femme de arabie saoudite ou de lire
en tout cas je compte sur tout le temps
ces exemples exemple à une femme qui vit
dans un pays libre qui a vu qu'il y
avait que des femmes avaient du mal on
va dire à adapter leur style de vie avec
leurs croyances qui a eu l'idée qui
s'est inspiré en fait d'une combinaison
qui existait déjà depuis des années qui
n'a jamais fait polémique c'est à dire
la combinaison de surf où les
combinaisons de plongée qui a été adapté
en fait pour les femmes pour qu'elles
puissent justement pratiquer leur sport
ou leur passion enfin pouvoir participer
à des loisirs avec leurs enfants
sans justement on va dire pas dénigrer
mais mettre de côté leurs valeurs et
leurs croyances et je voulais vous dire
que justement si le burkina ne contenait
pas porté que par des musulmanes
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
ne sont même pas religieuse croyantes ou
enfin qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
religion et qui le porte juste savoir
quand même ça c'est rare mais ça existe
il ya aussi des femmes qui sont
chrétiennes qui sont voilées de la même
manière que moi vous me prenez un peu
pour à la panne trois semaines là comme
dit pascal praud s'est excusé moi c'est
que vous essayez de me dire que ces
revêtements parmi d'autres choix non
jantes et hattmatt eu mais le fait que
c'est un choix qui a quelque chose à
voir avec votre identité ou culturelles
et religieuses connotation écouter en
fait je dirais pas pour ton coin il est
interdit au maroc d'après vous je ne
suis pas enseignée sur ses biens il est
interdit au maroc pourquoi parce que les
marocains savent que c'est une arme si
vous voulez de conquête des islamistes
alors j'essaie une conquête vous touchez
le tissu si vous souhaitez je vous
invite à venir le voir non mais
c'est pas un vêtement c'est un symbole à
la vie des chroniqueurs raymond tôt tu
dis non pourquoi moi le premier quel mac
elle nous a montré c'est pour moi c'est
pas un mur qui le premier maillot de
bain qu'elle nous montre vermorel non
partir des pantalons quand y'a les
manches moi je dis non parce que j'ai
été élevé moins ici on dirait que les
musulmans ici il arrive aujourd'hui il y
avait des musulmans il ya 20 ans il ya
trente ans et on n'avait pas ces débats
là et moi je trouve que ce qu'a fait
eric piolle c'est tout simplement
scandaleux et même vous vous devriez
vous être être pas content sur ce qu'il
avait mis ce qui vous a mis des femmes
aux seins nus à côté de vous je trouve
qu'il ya un bordel qui s'organisent ces
femmes n'ont permis à bord des six
heures parce que si je trouvais normal
que si on accède à des deux femmes ça
colle pas se couvrir on peut aussi
accorder à des femmes de ménage ça colle
pas il ya des moeurs en moi je veux pas
de voir des femmes au sein des marchés
s'affolent pas et où culturisme
joseph hamas en exil les femmes aux
seins nus vous gérez à côté d'une
vraiment des grands burqini trouve ça
très bizarre je prends une métaphore à
deux balles mais c'est comme si j'avais
dans un cube avec je demandais un jambon
beurre ça marche pas en fait c'est
bizarre de la scène métal
deux bandes mais c'est très bizarre elle
est assez parlante c'est très bien tu ne
peux ou tu fais un truc et je veux tu
être des horaires aménagés moi je suis
tolérant tu vas dans un shooter
reconnais tu va maintenant même si tu le
plus tolérant à chaque fois je
m'embrouille avec les gens qui sont
contre les rayons les rayons alors tu
dis ça te dérange en quoi les rayons à
la laisse tranquille ils vont manger je
suis le plus tolérant lys mc do qui
jouent au foot avec le nid jab ils ont
ça me dérange pas il ya pas de problème
mais dans la piscine moi quand j'ai
quand j'étais petit ça apportait je suis
un vieux con c'est que j'ai grandi avec
des défis j'aime bien aussi il n'y avait
pas s'il n'y avait pas cette escalade de
maintenance et burkini après ça va être
quoi ça va on va faire ça va être quoi
après un moment de joie quand je vais
dans des pays étrangers je respecte la
coutume dérange moi je la coutume du
pays étranger je m'amuse pas faire
n'importe quoi quand on me dit fais pas
ça parce que c'est pas bien mange pas ça
parce que c'est pas bien fait comme lui
mangent halal fait si je mens je vais je
respecte le pays je vais vous pédalez
réparation aurait dans une surenchère de
aujourd'hui c'est ça après c'est ça
c'est la manière se sont alors bien
glissé en allemagne donc dans la bile db
rossberg donc ne doit pas prononcer bien
rosalie et barbus bergues bon j'ai pas
fait de leurs gardes alors il ya donc ce
lycée où on a demandé il y en a un autre
je ne sais plus dans quel but on a
demandé aux lycéennes d'arrêter de se
mettre des mini jupes ou des choses un
peu trop courte parce que ça heurté si
vous voulez des gens venus d'autres
cultures et c'est tout à fait ce qui me
fait peur c'est à dire que si nous
cédons et quand je dis nous c'est
collectivement nous les français c'est à
dire tous les français et y avait
d'ailleurs beaucoup de musulmans qui
sont mon avis donc vous voulez mais si
nous cédons collectivement là dessus un
jour qui va se passer ce qui se passe
dans la réalité je ne peux pas les
habiller comme ça dans un certain nombre
d'endroits dans mon pays et pourquoi et
bien parce qu'effectivement des gens
venus d'autres cultures quand il voit
une femme habillée comme moi si vous
voulez pense que c'est une [ __ ] et donc
bah oui je suis il faut quand même le
dire excusez moi c'est la vérité vous
avez grandi dans une cité moi aussi à
epinay sur seine
c'était d'ailleurs pas comme ça comme
vous l'avez remarqué c'était pas comme
ça et donc très longtemps été un dernier
mot sur lequel je voudrais vous
expliquez moi je ne vous fait pas
l'injure de croire qu'on vous oblige à
le porter donc c'est pas du tout mon
propos et si vous voulez je trouve que
c'est un peu fort de café de me dire que
cp minispace que féministe et pas chacun
fait ce qui lui plaît si vous voulez non
c'est non l'hiver c'est moi vous
expliquer la liberté c'est pas chacun
fait ce qu'il lui plaît ça c'est
mcdonald's s'est donné comme défi la
seconde
c'est le slogan de mcdonald's bonne et
comme vous êtes et il ya des tas de pays
qui pratiquent exactement cette
conception de la liberté la nôtre est
plus exigeante elle vous demande
d'effectivement un mois quand un
poubelle a demandé à mes parents comme l
a demandé à des générations de gens
venus d'ailleurs de renoncer à un peu
parce que pour entrer
si vous voulez dans la merveilleuse
culture au sens large ne sait pas que
des libres la culture française qui est
aussi une liberté une émancipation de
lundi et ce que nous ne voulons pas dans
l'espace public si vous voulez ce que ce
qui n'est pas dans la tradition ni
politique ni sociale française c'est que
les groupes s'installe en tant que
groupe dans l'espace public on est
d'abord dont un citoyen français dans
les noms mais c'est gratuit alors
d'abord je serai à raymond raymond en
fait piol ils disent à dessein en fait
c'est un dangereux manipulateur il est
juste dans le clientélisme est en fait
il veut nous faire croire en fait il
nous tend un piège qui est un peu
grossier malgré tout sur et il veut nous
faire dire qu'en gros mais moi je suis
un féministe je défend la cause des
femmes en gros si vous avez envie de
vous mettre s'ennuie pas de problème si
vous vous voulez l'impudeur allez-y et
si vous voulez la pudeur avec les bikini
allez-y en gros c'est les opposer et
c'est ces ego en fait sa mue acté
burqini c'est les opposer sauf que moi
je le crois pas ça la demoiselle en
oncle pense que c'est un leurre je pense
que c'est juste un certain qu'ils
essaient de nous hypnotiser bâbord 91
cent des français sont contre donc il
faut pas croire que les français sont
pour le bikini et dans quel but parce
qu'en fait moi je pense vous le bureau
chinois les français parce que il ya moi
je suis française par exemple oui mais
oui mais dans les 20%
alors qu'il est en fait c'est pas un
vêtement comme les autres c'est pas
vraiment faire croire que c'est jeanine
le bikini n'est pas un vêtement comme
les non il est pas de connotation
religieuse de béquilles un vêtement
idéologique alors pourquoi mademoiselle
pourquoi mademoiselle à ce moment là
dans les pays où le birkin y est
obligatoire les femmes n'ont pas le
droit de se mettre à nu pourquoi on fait
ça ça marche pas dans les autres dans
des pays où le burkina est obligatoire
alors pourquoi les allemands ont pas
droit de se mettre vous un nul dans les
pays où le burkina est obligatoire et
ensuite gilbert devrait se renseigner
parce qu'il parle de la suède la suède
un orgasme en parlant
nationale traverse
majeur justement parce qu'ils ont cédé
sur ce genre de ch'nord oui bien sûr oui
bien sûr il ya eu des émeutes en suède
elle récemment sauvé nos maisons
tout est calme et donc je pense que
cette injonction à couvrir votre corps
par pudeur ses politiques et c'est pour
ça que moi je suis content moi je suis
pour que le corps de la femme soit gala
au corps de l'homme voilà j'ai mal à la
gorge
je vais vous surprendre mais je suis
plus gêné par les seins nus à la piscine
municipale va pour vous c'est gênant
et après
ça a été inventé en 2002 à 2006 en
australie et le nom après burqini fixe
et contraction de burqa et de bikini qui
s'est passé pas très heureux on aura
peut être bon ça c'est simplement fait
moins de bruit c'est ce que je suis
désolé il n'y a aucun pays dans le monde
il n'y a aucun pays dans les années où
le web est interdit aucun nom aucun reid
on attendait c'est donc un signe c'est
un signe religieux dans aucun pays du
monde le voile est interdit et aucun
pays le dos monde can not laïcité en
veillant sur la vo interdit à l'école
marche at on la croit je vois pas ce qui
est dérangeant est ce qu'on soit couvert
à la piscine honnêtement et qu'on
n'aille pas au delà du symbole et de
voitures des complots et doit toujours
dit voilà c'est parce que sa complice
arrêté que ces complots arrêté que c'est
combien non mais je veux bien arrêtée
subitement
musulmans
ils exercent dans l'antre yslow niveau
un monde meilleur tiens donc
tu vas trop loin
effectivement plus burqini des pâtures
et assure religieuse ça malheureusement
c'est maladroit parce que c'est faux
mais au-delà de ça quand on dit la
liberté notamment des femmes c'est de
faire ce qu'on veut non quand on vit en
société la liberté c'est de ne pas
choquer les autres c'est ça dans une
piscine faites ce que vous voulez mais
dans une piscine municipale ont fait pas
ce qu'on veut vous n'arrivez pas en
burqini on n'arrive pas à laisser un nul
si j'arrivais à poil j'arrive pas
possible tu vois ce que je veux dire on
ne fait pas ce qu'on veut faire c'est
parfois pour inscrire dans au nom de la
liberté je peux faire n'importe quoi je
peux arriver bien clément ont déguisé je
peux arriver à pois je peux arriver les
seins nus piscine municipale en vie en
société en société on doit faire en
sorte de ne choquer personne comme si
vous choquer quelqu'un par définition
c'est est ce qu'un souci c'est pourquoi
il va reproduire ce raisonnement il ya
plus de caricatures on peut que j'aie
non parce qu'avec votre raisonnement on
n'a pas le droit de faire des
caricatures va-t-on si vous dites on a
droit de choquer personne la france est
un pays où on peut être choqué par les
opinions des autres mais il ya ce que
j'appelle les moeurs et c'est pour ça le
bikini que vous le vouliez ou pas c'est
un symbole islamistes le burkina le
berliner c'est un symbole islamiste a
rassemblé par ailleurs - dre vous poser
une question très très fraternel jo il
s'écoula mois ce qui m'embête c'est que
vous voyez bien effectivement que ça
heurte une majorité de nos concitoyens y
compris des musulmans que je le répète
enfin d'accord ça choquait valeur
beaucoup de gens voulaient mais agnel il
ya des tonnes de pays où on s'est
encouragées
je veux dire la france est effectivement
ce pays singulier moi je pense que ce
que vous avez en échange c'est une
merveille à cette une c'est un cadeau
merveilleux d'entrer dans la communauté
politique française
mais moi j'en plus beaucoup à la lettre
les vies
qui sert à rien à part essayer de faire
peur aux gens bah placement à l'avis de
leurs canines si c'est ce qu'elle
sous-entend a dit attention si de demain
la société ressemblera cet état vous
dites que le banc alors que les gens
mais se heurtent eux qui à part les gens
qui ont
peur de la différence bastille pas non
pardon mais n'est pas grâce à leurs 80 %
des français plus qu'ils sont contrariés
peu importe on parle de sondage il ya là
bien mais gênant dans le burqini c'est
un progrès social les fameux
ya peut-être beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui ni qui ne se sentent pas à
l'aise d'aller à la piscine parce
qu'elles ne veulent pas se dénuder
partiellement étiez où j'habite grâce
aux burqini pourtant à la peine donc oui
c'est une avancée sociale coloris du
grand place le
désagréable alors que moi je suis
confiant
j'aimerais d'ailleurs
je vous dis moi benhaim s'agira vienne
question radia gilles verdez bea daniel
moreau dehors
le fait pas semblant de tomber dans le
piège et la rue frédéric piol qui en
fait fait juste un truc électoraliste il
est parce que il estime que ça va lui
rapporter des voix en fait il en a rien
à faire dès 1902 faire grise mine il se
dit simplement que ça peut lui rapporter
des voix et nous on est bêtement tous
collectivement tombé dans un piège qui
d'un côté nous mais l'extrême droite qui
manipulent de l'autre côté nous mais
l'extrême gauche qui manipulent au
milieu nous mais l'islam radical qui se
frottent les mains et qui est les grands
perdants de tout ça sont les femmes
musulmanes qui en fait elles leur disent
simplement si chez nous la paix celle
qui veulent mener sur ginès qui te gêne
dans celle de voir une femme en bikini
c'est parce que c'est un choix fort et
faible avancée du féminisme ce n'est pas
une avancée du féminisme peut comprendre
qu'avec ça j'aime ça parce que toi ça te
donne pas qu'un axe aux jeunes s'il vous
plaît j'avais dit béatrice à
l'américaine à la mer l'hôtel a parlé de
ronald mcdonald tiens ton
je cite je n'ai déjà dit sur ce plateau
quand j'étais petit toutes les
communautés face à ma patte s'était même
pas considérés comme des communautés et
les individus étaient tous ensemble
n'affichait pas le nient leurs opinions
politiques ni leur religion et tout le
monde s'entendait très bien on ne savait
même pas de quelle confession étaient
les uns et où les autres c'était parfait
aujourd'hui burkini pour moi ce n'est
pas un vêtement neutre je n'ai rien
contre les femmes qui veulent le porter
en tant qu'individu je dis juste que
c'est un message politique et de la même
façon que je n'aimerais pas que des gens
viennent avec des maillots avec la tête
de mélenchon de marine le pen ont deux
kits anti vaccin provoque sa foi tous
les jours la salle et que tout le monde
se met sans la figure à la piscine
municipale ce qui n'est pas le but on
vient là pour se détendre et donc c'est
pas un endroit pour faire un meeting
politique ou religieux je suis d'accord
message de ma mère la
foudre ont leurs propres papa une
certaine conception va dire de la pudeur
pense qu'ils en ont ras la foule le
gamma mer où il avait laissé un message
radio pas dû à ma mère a laissé un
message à elizabeth les mii je le dis si
elisabeth avec lui au maghreb vous avez
quand même non
elle a dû voir des musulmanes voilées et
c'était sans problème elle se baignait
même avec leur voile ce que vous
répondre à ma mère qui s'attaque à
lui répondre et bien précisément c'était
au maghreb quand mes parents sont venus
du maghreb ils ont renoncé à un certain
nombre de choses et encore une fois la
france à des moeurs très singulière nous
sommes le seul pays au monde si vous
voulez qui par exemple est votée cette
loi de 2004 contre le voile à l'école
pourquoi parce qu'on considérait qu'à
l'école où devait être émancipé de ses
appartenances c'était le lieu un
sanctuaire dans lequel on pouvait être
juste des élèves qui apprennent donc ça
marche et des jeunes filles musulmanes
n'ont pas quitté l'école d'accord cette
loi a été traité de raciste dans le
monde entier aux états unis partout pour
moi si vous voulez c'est notre
conception très singulière qui vient de
d'assez loin du vivre ensemble c'est à
dire que pour vivre ensemble il ya des
pays
où on pense que toutes les différences
est exactement ce que vous venez
d'expliquer très bien je dirais tu par
ailleurs vous allez complot pas qu'on
peut vous employer le mot que vous
voulez il y à des études là dessus il ya
des articles il ya des reportages il y a
aujourd'hui des organisations proches
des frères musulmans qui essaye dans
tous nos pays de séparer les musulmans
du reste de la société et de nous tester
ils acceptent le burkini demain leur
fera enlever leurs minijupes c'est ce
qui s'est passé en allemagne et bien moi
je voulus d'ailleurs il ya déjà des
endroits dans mon pays où je ne peux pas
porter de mini à ce genre de à dire là
oui mais ça bouge ça bouge excusez moi
ça devrait vous intéresser ça vous gêne
pas que je puisse lui arriver ça assez
radical sur le côté religieux déjà sont
contre le burkina il faut le savoir la
plupart des musulmans ne sont pas
favorables au burkina comme je le dis le
burqini c'est un choix vestimentaire
c'est des femmes qui a envie de
s'intégrer en fait tout simplement à la
société et ses tourelles un moyen
justement pour leur faciliter l'accès
pour pouvoir entrer à la piscine
profiter avec leurs enfants pour vittek
leur famille passé des bons moments
comme toute mère de famille comme toute
femme qui en vue de juste aller se
baigner tout simplement ça n'a aucun but
politique et si on a un j'aimerais bien
que vous me rejoindre pour vous
l'individu au pardon devant l'homme
pardon ça je sache combien je me suis
peut être mal exprimé je sais bien que
vous vous n'avez pas un but politique
comme individu jeudi que vous êtes
personne ne dit que vous êtes
l'instrument d'un combat politique et
idéologique
je n'ai jamais dit que vous comme
individu si vous voulez vous vouliez
mais en réalité il ya derrière cela des
gens un coup c'est burqini un coup c'est
la prière à l'université qui veulent
transformer s'ils voulaient notre façon
d'être avec la religion les questions
religieuses ont été au centre de
conflits en france depuis le 16e siècle
donc si vous voulez on ne les a pas
découvert aujourd'hui on s'étend payet
entre protestants et catholiques
ensuite les catholiques se sont employés
contre les laïcs si vous laisse donc il
ya eu énormément de conflit si vous les
voilà chacun ap anglais fort ça veut pas
dire renoncer à tout ça veut dire
renoncer à des signes qui à l'évidence
choque beaucoup de gens il avait donc je
suis désormais un peu marre d elisabeth
géraldine béatrice et même valérie si tu
n'aimes pas des femmes du plateau ce cas
les filières remo qui milite pour les
gardiens des moeurs il milite pour une
france qui n'existe plus une france où
finalement c'est ce que vous voulez les
gens qui ont envie de pratiquer la
religion musulmane n'en n'auraient pas
le droit parce que ça vous dérange parce
que il ya 30 ans peut-être qu'il le
faisait moins ostensiblement et c'est la
france que vous préfériez mais je vous
signale que le burqini il est
parfaitement légal lahlou est du côté du
burkini quand les lèvres quand les
villes avaient voulu interdire le
burqini sur les plages en 2016 tous les
arrêtés avaient été retoquées donc vive
le burqini vraiment ça me dérange pas du
tout en la religion musulmane ne dérange
pas du tout je les dis le rayon halal ne
me dérange pas tout ce qui est même le
vendredi quand la rue elle est fermée
parce qu'il ya la prière et que je dois
faire des détours mai 2000 ans ça me
dérange pas du tout je me dis qu'ils
vivent leur foi je suis content je suis
content et les rues sont fermées il ya
plein de monde ça ne me dérange pas que
j'ai aucun preuve un quart aux jeunes je
dis tout à l'heure vous avez dit on va
en famille avec notre enfant moi j'ai
une question à vous poser moi je prends
ce que eric piolle ce qui fait là c'est
n'importe quoi pour moi c'est je vais
pas l'insulté je me pour moi c'est un
imbécile non c'est un imbécile parce que
va pourquoi moi même en hiver très
content et je dis ce que je dis voilà
bon bah c'est pas grave à lyon je m'en
fous c'est pour moi c'est pas bien ce
qu'il a fait parce que
je crois qu'ils ont regardé chez lui je
crois qu'il est dans sa piaule
passé quand tu auras un papa deux
enfants et peut-être même toit avec une
deux femmes aux seins nus ou trois
femmes aux seins nus c'est à dire que le
papa veut que tu mettes de cette fuite
mais il accepte masse et des piscines de
l'erika les piscines des rich iott tu
mets une femme en burqini un papa une
maman et des deux trois femmes dix
femmes aux seins nus c'est la fête tout
le monde a les seins nus c'est bizarre
quand même moi mon père mon père il y
avait la pub take et douchy changer de
chaîne il voulait pas son cauchemar à
mon père c'était collaro la playmate dei
changer de chaîne direct avait une
pudeur comme ça et pourtant se trouve ça
bizarre de mettre une femme en burqini
et des femmes ne savaient pas
c'est pas pareil c'est pas pareil jour
votre avez chaud j'ai mon avis personnel
dessus on va dire mais je peux pas
l'imposer et moi ce que je sais que je
combatte la vie personnelle il vous
manipule le tel système oui erik cole et
vous manipulent forcément je vais pas on
va dire mais si cette courbe de tous
elles ont droit d'être appelé ce mois-ci
c'est justement
vous rester à côté du lait fermenté
savourer sa cote et le vernis très dur
ya quatre mois si ça me dérange je reste
pas à côté d'elle tout simplement mais
dans la même piscine comme ça vous
dérange qu'est ce que ça vous dérange
que vos enfants soient dans la même
machine
même une seule et même avec des saint
des seins nus à la piscine topless quoi
à côté de vos enfants 1 franchement oui
mais voilà et comment vous partez vous
diront que c'est grand comme ça comment
bouger je peux pas les enfants que la
plage d'ostende en émoi moi je remets
enfants à côté d'une femme topless
permet d'avoir mis ses pas le burqini
problème à lens est descendu basse et
éric poulouin fabula nova scotia sur soi
les singes lui fallait rien dire voilà
le burqini ne dérange personne les seins
nus ça dérange les gens parce que la
notation sanctionnent le burqini c'est
l'étape ultime de la sexualisation
puisque le corps on le cas des femmes
est tellement
plus que dérangeant en fait on a
personnellement les rôles aujourd'hui
caché son corps c'est devenu quelque
chose de sexuel
oui c'est parce que j'ai beau le cash
auriez pas si vous pensez pas que
c'était sa mort je n'ai
effectivement qu'ils ont été mutilées ou
il ya des femmes qu'ils ont justement
laissé aux parties ce qu'ils ont fait
une question mois après l'arrêt de son
estomac qui s'en servent le cadeau
précieux les radios y acheter ça vous
dérange plus que vos enfants soient à
côté d'une femme en topless ou d'une
femme qui porte le burkina et ça c'est
pas également avec elle nous fait croire
que ça
c'est bon moi je préfère les enfants
najac aux tic d'une femme en burqini
qu'une femme aux seins nus à ses seins
nus direct moi c'est que cette substance
est particulièrement les deux me dérange
je ne veux ni religion ni femmes aux
seins nus dans la piscine et je veux
expliquer aucun des deux ans mon enfance
a eu lieux de religieux chez bien dans
la pub faut expliquer ton enfant
pourquoi la dame elle est habile il
n'y a pas de discours politiques qui
instrumentalisent les femmes aux seins
nus bah oui c'est pas la même c'est pas
logique
merde c'est tout moi j'ai sur le même
plan en fait moi les deux me dérange et
je ne saurais pas comment expliquer un
an à mon enfant est habillée comme ça je
suis désolé
non mais moi j'attends de lui dit tout à
pas pourquoi il a 62 ans
non mais quand tu dis qu eric piolle est
un imbécile non il nous prend pour des
imbéciles c'est parce que en 2010 je
suis désolé en 2019 il ya eu des actions
coup de poing dans les piscines de
grenoble pour d'alliance ses alliances
européennes l'association dont on parle
beaucoup et il a dit que c'était
communautariste et trois ans plus tard
peut-être pour déjà il nous prend bien
bien pour des imbéciles et moi je pense
aussi que pourquoi il est il permet les
seins nus et le burqini c'est parce que
depuis la loi de 1905 on ne peut pas
dire que vêtements religieux février on
peut pas faire allusion à la religion
donc lui il se sert de la grande liberté
de tout le monde et c'est sur ça c'est
nous prendre vraiment pour des imbéciles
et moi je trouve que vous êtes
certainement très sincère pour vous
personnellement mais tout ça est
politique et voilà si on décrit penser
autrement il ya des femmes qui ceux qui
se battent en ce moment pour en
afghanistan pour l'amener au souk ahras
et je suis désolé je peux pas m'empêcher
de faire
je n'ai pas de gérer
des soutes par contre c'était ça non à
73% oui à 26 7 % jusqu'à eric piolle qui
vient de m'écrire un message qui me dit
je suis sur un nouveau projet les boules
à l'air dans le pays dit
choqué parce que oui donc j'avais juste
une question pour vous malgré tout à
l'heure que s'il y avait des femmes
s'ennuie bon vous préfériez quand même
vous éloignez on peut être c'est quoi le
éventuellement le nextep imaginer par
exemple qu'il ya un maître nageur pour
prendre des cours de natation homme est
ce que vous acceptez ou est ce que par
exemple vous avez un problème vous avez
besoin d'être secourue radio est-ce que
vous acceptez un bouche à bouche d'un
homme qui est là qui est un maître
nageur pour vous sauver voyons à dire
que jusqu où va sa voix la jonction de
réponse alors je vais répondre pour moi
ça me pose pas de problème et je vois
pas quel est le rapport avec le burkina
mais en fait normalement mais c'est pas
joli mais
c'est pas autorisé tout ce qui n'est pas
étonné par exemple je vois par exemple
ma maman elle est dans des quartiers où
elle en tant que médecin femme elle elle
voit que des hommes qui demandent des
médecins femmes qui veulent pas des
médecins hommes sont leurs favoris après
pour l'heure plusieurs refus catégorique
est ce que c'est c'est contraire à leur
religion ma joie ça peut être sa fin il
ya des femmes qui vont le faire par
choix religieux à des fins qui sont
juste pas à l'aise en présence d'hommes
tout simplement
pardo cher excusez moi mais est-ce que
vous pouvez quand même comprendre je
voulais encore une fois ça n'est
vraiment pas une question d'individus si
vous voulez mais y'a des cultures
minoritaires comme d'ailleurs si vous
voulez des tas de minorités sont arrivés
si vous voulez et encore une fois il ya
plusieurs fois est-ce que vous pouvez
comprendre qu'on vous demande est ce
qu'on peut vous pouvez comprendre vous
demande un certain type d'adaptation est
ce que vous pouvez comprendre que pour
la majorité vous avez beau nous répéter
que c'est pas religieux tout le monde
l'a bien compris que c'est
instrumentaliser en tant que religieux
que ça arrive à ma connaissance c'est
quand même des femmes musulmanes qui ont
demandé cette affaire du burkini ça
c'est pas passé devant est ce que vous
arrivez à le comprendre naturellement en
fait il ya des femmes présentes
à battre est évidemment
m